Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to The David
Pakman Show. Luke Beasley here filling in for
David while he is away. Don't forget to check
out my YouTube, Luke Beasley on YouTube or Luke
Beasley on any podcast listening platform if you
are a listener. There is a Texas GOP convention
over the weekend where a number of notable things
happened. One of the big takeaways from a couple
of these moments is that the far right isn't far
right enough for the extreme, you know, radical
right wingers that are becoming more prominent.
So what I'm talking about is Dan Crenshaw was
walking through an event and got aggressively
accosted by some right wingers, not liberals.
Were the left not going after him? It's these
far, far right people going after Dan Crenshaw,
calling him a RINO Republican in name only. Let's
take a look at this video and then we'll discuss.
Speaker 2: Eye patch McCain. Hay eye patch McCain.
Little eyebrows. McCain right here. Right out
here. Four years on west right now.
Speaker 3:
And red flag was too dead. That's ridiculous.
Speaker 2: Hey, Danny, why are you in the World
Economic Forum? Young Global Leaders, World
Economic Forum. Hey. Yeah. What's worse, one's
number you got, plus one number. Last one was.
Speaker 1: Number. So they're screaming at him,
calling him a globalist RINO. Again, that's
Republican in name only. And usually people call
other Republicans rhinos if they're not
pro-Trump enough or far right enough. And
then they also were calling him Eyepatch McCain,
which is a term Tucker Carlson coined, which is
why I never understand stop going after people's
physical features. Just go after their positions,
their policies. That's it. It's crazy. Or they're,
you know, lack of principles, whatever it is,
anything that's not physical appearance related or
the fact that he's, you know, has damage to one of
his eyes, you could see it seemed to escalate to
actual violence. I couldn't quite tell with that
video what happened. But from the reporting,
as well as what you could hear in the video,
it looked like something really got physical
besides just them kind of pressing up. And then
I guess one of the guys was very upset that Dan
Crenshaw was involved in the World Economic Forum,
which I know very little about. But Klaus
Schwab, he kept saying, is the founder of it I.
I don't know what his deal is with all of
that. But the crazy thing is Dan Crenshaw
is very pro-Trump and he's very conservative, but
he just barely sort of critiqued Trump and wasn't
the most, you know, outspoken. The election was
stolen person. He kind of avoided that question
and then he supports red flag laws
was one of the things they brought up.
And that's what you're angry about. That
tiny little difference between Trump and him
and between you and him. He's a conservative guy
and they're still not happy with them. It's crazy
because their actual policy differences
are so tiny. It just they you know,
Dan Kraushaar doesn't appear radical enough for
their liking because if you think about Democrats,
AOC and Joe Manchin, the difference between
the difference between those two people
is way larger than any Republicans in their policy
differences. And yet leftists aren't going out and
accosting Joe Manchin like that. In the spirit
of this, at the same Texas event Ted Cruz got
made fun of for being a Trump boot licker, but in
a contradictory way. You know, he first criticized
Trump a lot on the campaign trail and Trump
alluded to his wife being ugly and his dad may
have caused, you know, 911 Ted Cruz like you don't
talk about my family like that. So against you.
And then Trump wins the nomination and Ted Cruz
as well. So a guy walked up. He's not the hero,
but he makes correct points. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Erica, you know, remember, it's how
Trump made fun of your wife and you got
to become better in control. I know,
but why do you do that? You got to become best
friends with Trump after he makes fun of you and
your wife. Why do you do that? I understand you
don't want your you don't know. See, I do love
America. So you don't you care more about the
border between Ukraine and Russia than you care
about the border between Texas and Mexico. Why
is that? Why do you care about that? I know, but
why are you globalist? You're globalist, but you
know. Hey, Daddy, you there? You're a globalist,
and you know that. But. And that's why you're a
coward and a liar. And you know that. And I know
that. And that's why you're afraid to stand up
for when people are freezing and dying. You were
in Cancun, Mexico. You remember that. You remember
when were at the all inclusive buffet where people
are free to go. Oh, you remember that kid when
everybody was freezing? I that's that when people
are dying, you know? Yeah.
Speaker 1:
So, like I said, that guy's life is rock. Or if
you ever hear someone use the term globalist or
as David Pakman says, impersonating Alex Jones
globalist, most of the time I guess you could use
that term if you meant like someone who is pro
globalization and globalist or like there could
be, ah, okay, usage of that word definitionally.
But the way that it's used in politics is almost
always super conspiratorial and an indication
that someone's a little e, but the point he was
making besides that weren't wrong, right? I mean,
it can't be forgotten that Ted Cruz kissed up to
Donald Trump after Trump alluded to his wife being
ugly or maybe his dad did. 911 is what Trump was
spouting off about, and Ted was so brave at that
point, characterizing Trump as such a terrible
candidate. And then Trump won the nomination and
Ted Cruz is the biggest bootlegger. And then also
it shouldn't be forgotten, as that guy pointed
out, that Texas was in that big freeze and Texans
are or were suffering and he flew off to Cancun
and then blamed it on his daughters. That was so,
so weird. This is a complete sidenote, but during
that phrase, because it's popped up, this is
a crazy, cute story. At that point, my family,
we were all here and we had 12 puppies.
Not my my entire family wasn't here, but I was
here sister parents. And we had 12 puppies,
golden retriever puppies from a golden
retriever that we had and or we still have.
And these 12 puppies were like little weeks
old. And so whenever the freeze happened,
all the power went out. And if they stayed
out in our house when it got that cold,
they would all have died. Luckily,
we had one little space heater,
so we packed in this tiny little room. Use the
space heater to keep the puppies alive. It was
wild. And during all of that, instead of Ted
Cruz coming and helping us with our puppies now,
he could have helped other people. He was
off in Cancun living up the good life.
So. He's a goof ball, the guy who walked up
to Ted Cruz, but so is Ted Cruz. So he kind of
deserves it. And the points he was making were
definitely correct. And I love how Ted Cruz's
reaction is always just completely not address
what they're saying. He was he kept saying, like,
oh, I know you don't love taxes or you
don't want to defend taxes. Okay. Yeah, sure